Fleiss Alice just watching yeah just
watching will be probably a bit more
chill and zordons popcorn is all lowest
rated hey the only player rated below a
thousand talkie in the middle of Peck oh
I'm playing provisional but okay
opponent has other ratings interesting
I'm gonna play aggressively f3 did the
opponent Mouse lip not sure
usually the the reason why you play f3
is because you mouse slipped and you
meant to play king's gambit after he's
terribly weakening though because it
weakens diagonal and it prevents the
knight from developing to the best
square
I do want to play aggressively sometimes
before you play aggressive you just have
to complete development g4 what was g4
is g4 it's playable I want aleady v the
g5 actually that's kind of interesting
there's a crazy line though g v g5 takes
takes takes i'd lose it yeah like would
promote there wait no here here takes
takes takes o takes on then mate yeah
let's do that
Wow opponents so confident preme of d3
oh yeah d3 is probably a fine move i'll
complete development points still pre
moving fascinating I have each six here
I'm Bishop g5 yeah very natural d4 I
guess
it's not losing yet which is impressive
you're playing f3 on the move - I'll
fini fini wants to play the tournament
but it's 1 a.m.
ouch
ok opponent giving me gifting me a night
I don't even know if I want to take that
night I think what I want to do this
should still win a piece
ok opponents making questionable pre
moves well I could have taken with check
sure they've taken with check but ok I'm
winning winning one of these pieces I
saw your game so far but this is a nice
thing about Swiss like you like the
first round there's a huge rating
disparity and then as a tournament
progresses the gap gets smaller and
smaller and then competition gets
tougher and tougher if you keep winning
okay tap owning gifting me more things
don't take this yeah I think of my
opponents level the the best thing to do
to improve is to be be a lot more
conservative with just holding on to
material every chess player was at this
level at some points where you just
you're you're - I wanna say careless but
too generous in giving away material
check generous generous is such a nicer
word than careless I want to take but
then that would make me generous like I
want to get the get a night to a dark
square how to do that I have an idea
and then maneuver my queen here and then
trap the bishop and it's hard for a
white to actually solve the problem of
the bishop because it has no moves and
the King's tied down
I'm gift I'm gifting a pawn why am i
matched with a 1800 player that's the
nature of swiss pairings is there is a
formula where I can try and explain it
there's a Wikipedia page too but
essentially the top player at least in
round 1 the top player will play the
player in the middle it's a better way
to explain it
yeah so Swiss pairing was like the field
is cut in half based on reading and then
you you have two halves so the the top
the top of the top half plays the top of
the second half and so on
am i subbed to any other channels yes
actually subbed to a lot of channels
very often maybe not all the time but
I'll be gifted subs especially if I read
channels anyway um a Gauri's playing so
yeah I'll probably play gari at some
point think we're the two probably the
two favorites maybe there's 31 games
ongoing now 30 games ongoing what does
this position lock has cool pawn
structure Oh big rating disparity yeah
blocks up three pawns let's find a cool
game this interesting position
so yeah always in the first round that's
the first round is usually the most
unfair pairings but the point of Swiss
is that when like after the first round
then the same formula is applied so and
there there's some notion of tigrex but
everyone with one point will likely play
someone else with one point everyone
with half a point will play each other
so you almost always play someone with
the same number of points that you have
so by the end of the tournament you'll
be playing someone who's approximately
your strength yeah let's watch a game
it's another benefit of these Swiss
tournaments like there's there's time to
chill watch some games not kind of
commentate like too much
are there any active mods actually don't
know tog easier talky move out and I
thought oh let me allow that that I
faked yeah that fake you is I'm the
people on the lookup Swiss tournaments
and Swiss tournaments as a longer
explanation mmm is talking playing we
can watch tog II yeah cuz the scheme was
opening oh this is England gambit but
white was prepared
yeah 93 is very very smart move the main
shop is Bishop c3 Bishop before Queen d2
takes takes and then mate but yeah white
knew what what they were doing so can I
search its search for Talia
oh how you playing Oh Tonya's playing
someone 500 points a low-rated I tell
you you just took a pond port Auggie I
didn't want to say anything I didn't
want to spoil but opponent found the
best move yeah that pong was not meant
to be taken
I think whites still doing okay like
Queen d2
I'm sorry tog II the whole stream had to
witness that how it was bad timing I was
like the only move like I I joined the
game at this point the only move we see
you play is Queen Daisy for to be
careful not to judge a player based on
on one move
Oh taki playing London talk yeah I
thought you planned Kings gambit are you
learning for me okay so I'm somewhat
proud but okay one tip for taggi and all
the other London players when you run
into Queen b6 you don't have to directly
defend the pawn is a cool move here in
Knight c3 and then you make it so if
they take the pawn it's bad at your
Black is 95 so keep this idea in mind
it'll happen again and you might chop
some players where might literally like
trout the Queen somehow or you might get
this move if not a six I think you can
probably just rook be one Queen takes a
two and then move back take the night
and then fork tigey says in my mind I
did play h3 a long time ago each three
would have been nice
aloof for the King there's ninety three
more precise 93 is sometimes played
without the pawn on d5
for example like this position by the
three makes more sense because there's
some idea of Knight c4 but the pawns
already on d5 then then you should play
next to three because then it's just
more centralized if you played nine a
three then a six and your Knights a bit
misplaced baton with the clip or rubbing
it in anyway okay tog e1 one loss does
not mean the end of the world same goes
for the all the other players who have
zero points there's five more rounds
nice comment from this is slash finally
reached a 1300 rating nice job yeah
thanks for your comments appreciate it
what is taggi a person or a mean both
also an emote but I don't know if anyone
truly knows 11 games going boo
so we have we have a rook ending between
Perry and eco so 14 interesting see what
opening people are playing there should
be five shot a solid box surviving a
long time hmm yeah generally in a rook
ending where you're down pawns you
should avoid eruption so black should
better resistances like move the rook
somewhere far away
okay so games should be wrapping up
which came in over this game this is
interesting between two 1800s blocks of
a pawn but is it actually that useful
I don't want to say much like I don't
want to give away too much but yes we'll
see what happens blocks down a lot of
time okay now it's easy draw I don't
think yeah I don't think there is any
any chances they're coming yeah at some
point like these pawns get traded then
whites King just wins the back pawn Hey
it's chronic pain I've never been so
excited to say hello to chronic pain a
chronic pain yeah yeehaw yeehaw is that
like greeting or that's just in that's
an interjection expressing excitement
six games going what does this game oh
the king but waits so long time
man this King the king the King was the
most active piece oh and this time
driving me crazy every move he's getting
below a second Tyler don't flag a crazy
position
oh those are so many plot twists I was
the Queen hanging yeah the Queen was
hanging the white had no time this could
be the longest game all right let's go
back see these this game is interesting
oh why senior adverse awkward turtle two
names I recognize yeah that was a nice
very nice play by black writing meet and
then Knights got traded GG oh look at
this position CL smith game drawn was a
fifty move rule both players just agreed
on a draw that's so wholesome yeah this
is just this is easy draw like you can't
force me with two knights honestly I
probably would have tried as black
because you can still hang mate in one
if you're white oh buying buying GF 50k
says that was me
yeah good fights now there's cases where
White has a pawn like let's say I'm Matt
but imagine White has a pawn I'm like f2
then it's probably winning for black
there's a whole Wikipedia article on the
sort of position let's go back oh this
games still going compiler converts
look simpler than earlier also White has
more time than earlier
yeah that's the type of endgame almost
never happens but it's also it could be
fun to study I'd say it's not super
necessary there's other games that you
should probably study before that one
Hey Odell Looby welcome back you're
joining slightly late but um yeah for
those maybe just joining or for those
who haven't joined the tournament yet
you can still join with a join command
and let's go back to tournaments so all
the games finished 30 seconds until next
rounds why is there a one-minute break
because I think that's the lowest I was
able to select it gives a chance for
everyone to take a deep breath
probably a few deep breaths some some
water yeah this is like flavorless tea
who's in first bill Bob what good
tiebreaks okay playing another another
person so another reason to do Swiss is
to like just get games against people
who maybe wouldn't normally get to play
me okay we're gonna have a two Knights
attack
I'm Queenie to interesting move 97 would
make things really interesting
reinforcing okay doesn't happen if 97 I
had a 96 meet no this is actually a
mainline and I have 623 idea Bishop b2
the opponent was wise with the order
though II 6v6 does blocking the bishop
well okay it's playable I'm gonna play
like g4 g5
I think the idea is a pollen storm is a
queenside castle maybe put the bishop on
d3 pieces find some nice coordination
the Queen actually could sit very
happily on h3
I give 95 Queen h3 or queen g3 but
you're still completing developments
can I meet with two bishops yes I can
but I really haven't had to I was
watching a streamer or the other day I
think it was normally not a chess
streamer but has like over a million
followers on Twitch and they were
streaming 24 hours of chess
I think his name is box box and he was
trying to learn how to meet with two
bishops and the to Bishop me it can be
frustrating because it's so easy to
corner the King but then to actually
deliver me that's it's not so intuitive
and it's also easy for especially like
beginner players to stalemates okay I
want to play off for g5o tag you says
this is first time playing on the PC how
maybe the first of many with the
introduction of Swiss yeah it's really
cool that box box has been streaming
chests like consistently there's all
these streamers now who have like giant
followings from random video games that
are now like streaming chess
occasionally opponent wants to destroy
me I think it takes a file opens I just
want to meet yeah g5 it's got some g5e
months that's actually a nice move the
whole idea is to remove the pawn and the
knight and then meet so if take so I've
removed the pawn and then I'll play
Knight g4 it's actually hard to stop
like if the knight moves here then I
just take and G file action
yeah c6 was a hanging pawn but it's all
about the King side hey it's super
banana earlier there was banana party or
toxic banana party I have a banana it's
going right hey it's Nicola thanks
Nicola about 1000 bits upon please 97
trying to hold on for dear life well
it's probably not like that's probably
the best try given the situation I could
take I could vote Ted's gathered maybe
but probably not
it looks kind of fun yeah I think all
I'll take care still prepare this if g6
I might sack I might just take and take
yeah shout out to Nicola this is also
been streaming I think a decent amount
so opponent plays g6 so if I take take
that's nice but if I take take could be
nicer I think I'll play Brooke g1 I'm so
indecisive which pawn to take that I'll
take neither upon and now I probably
just want to take this pawn and crash
through with a rook
[Music]
yeah all the pieces are working together
like the I guess with exception of this
rook and the king they're in quarantine
hmm
I kinda just want to ignore that and and
crash through wow there's there's so
many double checkmate possibilities if
takes and I I double check and then King
here and then double checkmate
because the bishop also attacks the king
if takes takes and then here the night
of sevens double mates and a queen for I
[Music]
don't think black surviving this
there's no chucks actually there's one
check this is a Chuck I could pre move
mm yeah let's do this it's me than -
it's not gonna be double checkmate
because of the bishops box but that's uh
it's nice finish the pot and play the
role the alpha0 pawn I think my
opponents at least one kind of early
mistake was playing east six blocking in
the bishop you do not be careful like
developing the bishop ensuring that it's
not gonna get kicked around but I think
this position calls for Bishop f5 and
then then e6 and it's a bit more bit
more active this theory it's a theory
here Oh so b3 was straying away from
theory I'm 95 also interesting but yeah
Bishop f5 I think is a the simplest move
to to understand if I ever executed
Bishop Bishop in night mate in a game
not in the tournament game I've done it
I'm sure I've done it online at some
point but yeah I can't remember when I
don't think I've I've probably done it
on streem just as like illustration
maybe against like an engine or
something but yeah it's one of those
engines it doesn't happen too often but
it's good to know for sure
okay back to tournaments so let's watch
gari-gari-kun Gary giving him so many
shoutouts yeah I don't know
oh I wanted to ask if there's any likely
chess mods leach as admins or developers
and ask why we chess is not detecting
streams I know it's been detecting like
some people's fiends but not everyone's
and there's been no front page like
promotion tag is also playing so Gauri
how Gauri has so many things on the
kingside I think the other day like me
chess was doing some update maybe it's a
Swiss update that messed with something
I don't know how Gauri going in for the
a check this is a situation after white
makes the next move all explain if white
makes the next move White's so flustered
by Knight f3 so I was gonna say when you
only have one legal move like way it's
only legal moves king each one you
should play it without thinking maybe
what was trying to take but that's
slightly on illegal I tweeted me chess
yeah I'll probably just message there's
there's a few admins that are usually
pretty responsive
how would you recommend learning
openings there's a bunch of ways to
learn openings these days I mean good
old classic books is video lessons go on
YouTube I think when it comes to
openings a first step is to kind of
choose what openings you want to pursue
and then finding resources based on
those openings and there's some books
covering just one specific line or like
whole repertories and it's important to
get experience too so just playing like
playing a bunch of games in whatever
openings you're trying to learn and then
trying to improve upon each game and
looking at your games afterwards too
let's watch the lights in here mmm nice
Amir probably would not I would not
wanna be watched here but as resolved
she okay big rating differential wait
what happened to whites rook something
happens Oh
bad things happened a sniper Bishop from
a7 took on f2
let's go back to the tournaments Oh tog
II I missed it
ooh deepest apologies Oh Oh the problem
could be on twitches end because twitch
has been doing these weird updates as
YouTube showed on ah yeah I think we
just uses some I love it's twitch API
they have some mechanism to like to
search for category and stream title
fair enough okay let's watch another
game I assume Gauri won this game looks
interesting shine off verse Bham chess
Bham chess about 200 points higher rated
the dalip on thank for bishop it's gonna
be a time scramble Oh Gauri once I could
end up playing Gauri very soon and Gauri
knows all my London ideas hmm I'm
already trying to think what will play
against Gauri
if Eric isn't playing chess in the
stream of that normally you'd be
detected yeah and twitch I set the
category so if I'm not playing chess
I'll have the category as something else
like sometimes I'll scream Scrabble or
or geoguessr so as far as I know Lee
chess will promote streams if you have
chest category and if you mean you need
to set up a streamer profile and mention
Lee chest out org in the title
interesting end game blacks up to pawns
going after another pawn but both
players very low on time I'm black about
to flag no the check was so flustered
Locke can just play this and the spawns
gonna fall it would still take some
technique that's unfortunate though
that's why time is relevant one game
going White's having the the bishop hair
against the non disappear
Oh Sauron G quoting something-something
[Music]
rate limited by twitch I don't know what
that means but hopefully developers can
confine the solution magnesia there's
always workarounds what just happened
white lost a bishop hair oh I see so two
bishops answer rook but now one bishop
against just a king Bishop g7 going for
the endgame fianchetto now it's a race
unfortunately like White has a finish
line and black has just a pit of sorrow
because yeah the bishop defends upon him
from a distance
oh the quote was from me chess forum a
Jana gotcha okay good to know
as long as like they're aware of the
issue and I guess yeah you can't always
control like third parties but you can
always adapt okay dr. tournaments mmm so
gari
have we only played two rounds yeah it's
only been two rounds 112 players
so I still really don't know how pairing
system works if it's like using the
traditional Swiss formula or if it's
using like if it's basing it on reading
or tiebreaks if it's based on reading
that I won't play Gauri next I'll find
out soon enough
tigey number 65 tag you have to finish
number seven that would be the most
aesthetically pleasing number for you so
there's four more rounds people can
still eat joint I think but not after
this round so probably now it's too late
hey I'm playing someone who's game I
just watched as a reserve good luck
no don't don't self-destruct Alexa also
I had to move Alexa because that wasn't
working and what is this that's a fine I
do outlets in this move I the game the
other day what was it
I somehow chopped this Bishop like 92
and then BAM I had to throw in a six so
also who is that big that big Alex
thanks for subbing and could try trying
to destroy Alexa so 92 I need to anyway
I feel like I analyze this with Angela I
don't think a six was a best move but it
is a move this Bishop is awkward I have
maybe two threats to ideas okay not d4
but if the light moves on maybe d4 I'm
really bad with arrows
I feel like that 3d game kind of messed
me up
I had to adjust slightly but the center
is so nice this is I guess like one
reason I have not been playing much Java
London at least in the standard move
order this is such a nice line Bishop f5
I felt uh yeah I just failed to consider
that that's a good move because now this
pawn is kind of in danger
I play Queenie 7 I might not be I
thought it was like doing very well but
I might be fighting to equalize cuz I'm
down upon take stakes
so I'm looking at takes takes takes and
then takes and I'm just down upon
Queenie 7th and d5 would be tender oh
but maybe I take with Queen
probably gonna have to try it this is
not what they wanted a six was probably
too slow it's gonna get messy obviously
chess has we just gone down this
happened to some people the last
tournament but other people were okay
let's try this this is very shaky
position there's so much pressure
against both Center pawns let me see it
and open I'll play chess blue tab
yeah it seems completely fine to me it
could be like your location based on
server and deepest apologies to those
affected also I'm losing a pawn actually
yeah I just did I guess failed to cross
my mind that the knight was overworked I
thought my and I could take but upon
hangs
so yeah this is not pretty
it was really not pretty I have two
bishops though do you have the bishop
hair I wear shoes enjoying enjoying the
stream nice to hear yeah this is my
second swiss tournament in a row their
second swiss tournament in the last what
like 15 hours because i streams maybe
the last 20 hours I scream very early
morning yesterday technically so I'm
down upon position could very easily
deteriorate yeah I should I'll make a
swiss command because people people you
know a lot of people are asking still
like what's Swiss idea for may have to
save the queen
happy six-month anniversary hey he
bought the good work Eric Pete Weaver UK
happy six months Alexa what time is it
in UK oh oh that's actually reasonable
wow it's fear it's fear dragon 64 I
assume that's a chest streamer actually
haven't heard that name before
thanks for reading with hundred fifty
nine people welcome people like Creek
gifts great gift time just for all the
new raiders takes takes Knight g4 King
here Queen here and then meeting ideas
it looks very shaky because there's
there's King g3 but then h5 when in
doubt Yolo
when in doubt go Greek yeah I've never
been to Greece but it's a fun sacrifice
yeah thinks star dragon I'll have to
check you out
shoutouts star dragon 64 yeah if you're
just joining I'm running a tournament
it's a swiss tournament and
unfortunately i think it's too late to
join but people can still maybe try
using the joint command there's two
moves here there's Queen g5 or h5 this
is very shaky position but shaky for
both of us so much turbulence Oh star
dragon known for his fear crafts
what's a fear craft is it something to
be afraid of wait if you're dragging her
star dragon Oh fear dragon did I say
start doing it oh it's Starcraft weights
I'm so confused
64 signifies chess though because 64
squares I'm not gonna highlight all of
them oh it's star drag no it's it's
sphere dragon yeah yeah cuz its man my
my verbal memory is suffering anyway
it's time it's time to focus so night
here it's very devious why it wants to
run this way Thank You Gooch quintuple 5
I play queen I want to play Queen g5 and
then that's so close it's so close to
actually working but it's not working
like because the King was just gonna run
I could play pawn g5 mm-hmm I mean
there's there's Queen g5 King f3 Knight
h2 and I win the rook but I just run out
of fuel I probably have to do something
let's buy Queen g5 trying trying to make
the King die in fear but yeah the King
the king can run and that hide
it's a worst of yeah this is like the
worst possibility for me I just I take
run out of some attack after a king out
3 I would really like to just take my
knight and then mate
anyway maybe time will save me a slight
time advantage material wise I'm just
down a full night and King got three
good move
I should probably hold off on saying my
best moves for my opponents from from
now on I mean okay night eh to win
something at least I'm not H - keenie -
alright yeah let's try it
it's still a fights button I'm much
worse here this is very sneaky move I
want to play g5 make the knight move and
then pawn storm I was running this too
but opponents saw it oh I still have I
still have this move though okay King
here I can take King here maybe Bishop
g4 and it's getting complicated
complicated is probably good for me at
this point given the time situation I'm
low on time - hmm g5 takes takes
let's try g5 it's got some g5 emotes now
I'm turning to castle maybe with Czech
defending my oh my rook was hanging
eirick was hanging but opponent didn't
take it
wait what I believe this move castling
looks too risky
Oh
what is this game I can take on an F 2
each 4 is another move
take some lefty with Queen okay let's
try this
the Queen can't infiltrate cuz and I
just take hey let's go I called that as
a free queen and now let's win this
thing mm-hmm
okay let's just put in a a g3
yeah there's increments so I'm not gonna
flag I'm better not flat
idea Rock Cafe Bishop c5 let's defend
the pawn Oh upon still fighting Wow was
this it still should be winning though
just a crazy game well uh yeah I
actually I do want to get the pawn to h3
and then take some Queenie to mates yeah
white defending let's take this pawn now
I have outside pass pawn save the king
queen f2 perhaps I'll push this pawn
there we go if you're then take stakes
here and then meet ok well the game lets
difficult but got the job done good
fight as resolved as reserve in the chat
using light profanity I actually I had
to YouTube asks like for ad purposes if
there's any profanity in videos and for
my my upcoming upload I had to toggle
light profanity due to one of Feingold's
comments anyway um yeah thanks for the
game I would be pretty upset if I was
white so I was so so close to winning
I had White's real probably better here
if you take then these pawns fall but
the Queen wonder it didn't didn't quite
help
please explain move 26 move 26 oh yeah
maybe this wasn't so so if I take here
the issue is the King kind of finds
safety I couldn't take a draw here I was
trying to play for more than a draw and
I thought I actually thought my king
would be less safe if I somehow play on
and then queen g6 is coming these pawns
were hanging he just looked I didn't
look that creates so I took my throat to
threaten this and basically to defend
the Queen and when I took here I knew
that I was setting up it wasn't really a
trap but I knew that I was covering
Queen g6 because Mike my queen is
basically X rating the diagonal so yeah
hopefully that makes sense
that was a long game Wow all the other
games finished gauri also Algar e is big
competition so there's there's three
more rounds
esra Ze'ev says amazing game yeah thanks
for the game that was interesting the
Greek gift probably wasn't objectively
that great and for the most part white
defended well but all it takes I guess
is one mistake but even after losing the
Queen it was still a fight am I gonna
play Gauri
what there's eight players with three
three more rounds two to the third is 8
hmm so there should be a clear winner
after after three rounds playing pair
play d4 oh tigey is tired it's 6:00 a.m.
in Iceland Wow what's the Sun like and I
said it's probably still dark right but
you're approaching yeah you're
approaching longer days I would imagine
it's 8 a.m. in Switzerland hmm yeah all
these places I want to travel to I was
in Switzerland for one day and saw yeah
saw almost nothing saw the airport okay
London time opponent deep in thought I
play some kind of mainline yeah 97 I've
seen people play I would argue it's not
the most harmonious square for the night
because it's sometimes overlaps with
with this night let's play c3
like in general the the knight wants to
be on c6 okay it's so playable what's
good counter play against the London
there's a bunch of things to play I did
give a lecture for a st. Louis chess
club it's called black wins against 1.d4
I also have a study on the chess as a
public study it's called how to play
against one d4 so people can google
those Queen h5 looks nice
threatening means oh we did the game
crash oh yeah I think I said this
earlier but Swiss is still in beta mode
so there might be some unfortunate bugs
which I like I've been hearing but
haven't encountered myself at least yet
here I'm trying to attack trying to make
the pieces work together then they
probably wants to come in it's very
possible I'll slide the Queen over and
then push the H pawn because it is hard
to attack without having some open file
for the rook to come into play hmm
that's a move probably rip b1 safe and
sound
yeah Balaam oh that means that I think
they're still testing for bugs
okay so reinforcing me five we could
just trade everything like takes takes
takes takes Bishop f6 takes takes and
then I'm probably not better but I'm
probably not worse also take with Bishop
I'll take with with knights and keep the
disrepair yeah so here it's some
decision because taking is possible that
I kind of like Queen g3 keeping control
over 85 I don't want to allow back to
play Pawnee five so I want to still have
a piece here if takes takes it's hard to
remove the Queen four black from e5 in
Queen g3 coming it's also preparing this
push so I'm probably not intending to
castle leave the King's just gonna chill
on e1 and then this pawn advance full
try and make the bishop and rook happy
Queen g8 is very wise though idea to
play Queen f6 and force a trade
hmm yeah we're gonna get some ingame so
I'll play h4 accepting the fact that
we're trading okay enough six would be a
very risky free move if that doesn't
play Queen f6 and h5 s coming but yeah
and I thought this takes a night before
and this this basically prevents a 500
baht could take and play e5 and then the
bishops very strong on e fourth yeah
I'll make a command maybe after after
this game okay so now he fives probably
the go-to move so in end games of
bishops of the same color you want your
pawns on the opposite Clara of the
bishop
still have to be aware of tactics like
g3 Bishop c6 f 4 d 4 and probably rock
h2 there oh there's also rook after 3
but work out for you Bishop e2 and then
still f4 ok yeah I just want to get the
smiley pawns and now both these pawns
are gonna be fixed on light squares for
probably a long time to come
the D files now now the only open file
so it's probably gonna be some some
staredown have to be very careful
because if I play root t2 or up t7 I
might just be losing rook t1 mm I guess
rook t1 Bishop f3 Wow I'll probably have
to start calculating a keen pawn ending
there's also a Bishop c4 here makes a
ton more sense play Bishop c4 cuz I'm
controlling all these squares so there's
no like infiltration points for black
and e6 is weak but Bishop here that I
just pin I double up and pin and
probably win so Bishop e5 I mean it
looks natural and it's gonna lead
probably to a staredown again on the d
file opponent opponent place safe so h5
is a move rook d2 makes sense it would
be nice to trade a pair of rooks a very
positional and game I like my chances
though like white definitely has some
small inch don't know if it's enough to
win though but it's type of position
very pleasant to play in lit scheme he's
like make a bunch of quick moves blocks
always pretty much tied down now there
might be a bishop d5 I do have to watch
out for so I might I might actually play
a 3 here ensuring that if there's a d5 I
can just avoid the trade
it was a question though how I make
progress like I want to optimize I want
to put the King here and then what to do
some idea g4f five even ideas of King
III bring the rook to h2 and then each
five or even King III h5 takes on that
f5 we'll see what black is up to yeah so
now I don't want to play this in a lot
work do you want play rook I'll try and
play like some what you McCall it's cat
and mouse really just Mouse
what's my plan in Bishop e2 the move
you work here first everything on darts
where's except my bishop
I'm just trying to drain time for my
opponents that's kind of working it's
like Leroy black is doing okay I'm gonna
put my Bishop on on d3 at some point I
do want to play this hh5 move and I
prevented the rook from from coming in
in the event that I do play rook F to
block ever plays h5 and this is G pawns
week yeah so h5 will be the breakthrough
nice move because of the now the pawns
are very delicate
if king f7 and I take and then crash
through with my rook if takes line I
probably end up winning H pawn so h5
might actually just win a pawn here
there's rook e8 but then I take in my
rook GA takes in rock 8 7
oh that's one move I I fail to consider
it so I could alpha zero I could also
just take win a seven
I think practically this is probably the
best try for black well okay let's let's
take win a pawn if pawn takes here here
and then takes on g6 always repeat I can
I can go after a g6 that's probably the
the best approach and black can't defend
this pawn I take and then threaten this
fun can f7
no King f7 ok so we're just simplifying
it'll be three connected pastors do I be
greedy
the greedy move is this probably the
best move is Keaney for
but what to do yaki for two two pawns is
enough my five might have to be careful
here actually I'll start with Chuck
at least I have time to like just check
things and not mess up hopefully f6
looks really nice
it's kind of just a race where now this
pawn will be stopped or even like if
push I I just pushed in then I promote
first and then I meet I think cuz yeah
rogue f1 I have Brooke f6
okay that was nice
nice positional game has one V's like
slightly imbalance and games where like
once I got the pawn to e5 it was quite
pleasant um I'm not sure if I had an
improvement here oh you need a command
okay I'll make a command five games
ongoing Oh Gauri
Gauri also perfect so there's there's
four perfect scores and this is another
thing about Swiss is like at least
compared to arena there's usually no
like there's no runaways as long as like
you kind of you have a sufficient number
of rounds with like based off the number
of players at this link this link yeah
so I'll add this as a Swiss command
the green number oh so this is a number
of points the the Far column is the
tiebreak and this is some mathematical
formula if you want to read up the link
making this command people can click on
that okay so the rest of the games ooh
what is the scheme
well this position I don't know what's
going on but it looks cool
wide about to flag what the position man
wakes up a rook
but these pawns are terrifying I'll be
streaming at least two more games
hey it's chess Jack just Jack I have I
have hand sanitizer named after you
every man-jack yeah black promoted but I
could have even promoted and like here
probably simpler but black showed
dominance by by moving the King in the
scheme
[Music]
okay final game black very wise always
check actually I'll stop I should stop
saying things so black trying to meet oh
it's been a it's been a no Mike or Ben
thing what does this name Bob Pollin
Nike yeah black black does a good job
not still meaning I was gonna say always
check
cuz I'm that's not stalemate anyway um
okay the suspense is growing oh there's
a there's five five people with four
points so there is potential actually
for two perfect scores I guess usually
the bottom player will play the play a
three and a half interesting
wait Talia can add commands I guessed I
had companions so now there's a tog II
come in beautiful I'm gonna play gauri I
don't think so but we'll see oh I'm
playing I'm kind of alright okay good
luck oh let's play a Sicilian I'll
probably just stick with my oh never
mind but yeah I'll stick with my my
usual repertoire I was ready to play
time on oh so mean lion Smith morale
[Music]
wait if ty you can add commands he could
have added the Swiss command to yes he
was probably playing though Oh Julian
would have played Julian you joined too
late and it's even too late too late
join that's so sad
how do you remove commands I think the
same the same thing but exclamation
points commands remove our commands to
elite maybe but you have to spell it
right doggie
okay opponent playing some kind of
theory this is mark a sermon prep but I
already tell that my point sort of out
of crap okay it's still gonna be
somewhat of a fight yeah there's kind of
a trap a line if I were to take it would
not end well for me if takes takes takes
there's rookie one and then I think
Queen be a queen g4 or followed by
Bishop f4 is winning for whites that's
not the mean move but why isn't it not
the mean move me move was Bishop f4 and
guess the problem with this is I can
take I am Avalon
I am Avalon I have I have I have your
game Avalon
thanks for something I've been using
this Avalon game as my mic stand
to remove vibration when I move my mouse
yeah thanks for subbing for six months I
want to play b5 you get castle 295 also
legal move
hmm so usually I would have this
position with a six and Bishop f4
included so actually b5 makes that makes
sense if a six and Bishop f4 were
included then busy d5 would be very
strong but there's a d5 here I can take
on d6 or maybe even just take on d5 I
know Marcus Herrmann has like very deep
rep at least after Bishop f4 instead of
96
and it looks like maybe at first glance
it looks very uncomfortable with this
pawn wedged in my position defended by
the Queen my queen looks passive this
rook is kind of stuck but the good thing
is that this bishops gonna come to life
and I'm also up upon but still a
question like how to proceed accurately
I know there's some night before idea
hmm Queen b6 there's some logic to Queen
b6
and go play this feel like that this
move is useful in a lot of lines if I
played Bishop d7 my queen would still be
stuck there's a line where h3 I was
planning Knight here
I was gonna say that
oh then Bishop e3 mm-hmm is this crazy
move
oh I may have gone wrong here okay let's
try this I was gonna say that in some
line like take stakes I'm preventing
Queen d4 I guess my queen is still kind
of a target here yeah probably have to
play Queen d8 not so pretty I could have
taken with check but only helps white
activate the Queen hey it's Aakash
I'll cast your elites we're playing the
second to last round so anyone just
joining you'll have to I guess just
watch which is probably less stressful
than playing but maybe slightly slightly
less exhilarating also shout-out to
Aakash do I have an akash command gosh
maybe not
okay shoutout Aakash people should
follow Aakash hmm yeah there's pressure
here I'm thinking just Bishop e7 like
what's the worst that can happen
take stakes or stakes on a seven which
does not look so scary
yeah I can't complain here this is
looking very reasonable relatively equal
on time that's a move yeah that's a move
I probably want to take or Queen f6 the
Kuna would like to activate 90s b5 and
it's tricky
I could take Queen takes Queen Queen f6
let's try that
Oh Bishop takes Bishop takes Queen g5
how does white not get mated it's so
nice my my piece
my knight controls these two squares so
there's no Queen defense
I'm also threatening neither three here
a lot pawns pinned but the pawns also
attacked so White has to play some ugly
pawn move and then I have three and then
I win the rook well I probably just
assumed that he was attacking my night
and the knight would have to move but
never assumed yeah Queen takes would
have been stronger because the bishop on
u3 prevented Queen g5
so yeah I don't know wait the every move
is ugly for lights King hath one can
have one I take and then Bishop a three
wins a queen
actually linking f3
I just routed everything walls apart for
light cuz I take and then take and then
g2 Falls g3 it's still weakening to
light squares I'm kind of sympathizing
with Manya my opponents pane the Smith
Mura it can be a very venomous opening I
guess I was slightly fortunate my
opponent wasn't super well prepared I
played a sermon in the slide a sermon
got like a winning position from the
opening somehow I held on for a draw
this is like over a year ago yeah it's
weird that that white just doesn't have
resources to defend g2 as this bishop
wants to teleport but still nine f3 yeah
no other move really to consider
always repeats just for just for the
lulz hoping for Keaney to bonk loud
let's go
you too I win the Queen
okay I'll probably end up taking the
rook I could also go this way but I
don't want to repeat three times so
let's take a rock and then probably rook
c8
now white still has bishops this bishop
isn't so effective against the pawns
this pawn actually like it's not causing
too much headache
I'm Bishop e5 and Queen I 5 is a nice
move because this pawn is actually hard
to defend g4 Queen f3 resigns with 0.11
seconds left
thanks for the game I'm kind of all
right yeah for this myth more players
out there this is this line is is best
for White Knight d5 e5 but white should
play Bishop f4 and the main line is a 6
yeah the yada and there's a trap here b5
even though it's core as well for Block
B 5 is Matt with Bishop d5 this should
be a computer approved something
computer will eventually get +4 whites
yeah
and then if castling is the best move I
think h3 and 95 probably it's best to
look at s women's games whereas s
Freeman each 300 maybe rook e1 wait I
have to filter yeah master of mayhem the
world's leading experts on the morale oh
yeah night before is some weird move
that no one knows I probably would have
played it because I know it but most
natural is this and then White's just
better anyway let's go back to
tournaments
ooh gory also wants so there's there's
this will be interesting
I'm probably gonna play gari my tie
breaks are really you know Gary's tie
brakes are really bad but they're still
games going so the tiebreaker
I think based off how your opponents
have done or are doing
it's very possible I'll play chess Kim I
really thought I was bound to play gory
VI use the Swiss commands for some
reason
nightbot doesn't like faq sorry but I'll
let me allow that do you keep your
videos posted on Twitch after your
streams yes
yeah I'm assuming you're asking that
because you want to go back and watch
everything I said about our game yeah
the the twitch vods save for 45 days I'm
trying to get in the habit because I
don't post everything to youtube but I
do try link just download all my vods
just for historical sake
it takes up space though also exporting
I was um I spent like a good hour to
editing a video earlier and I exported
it at high quality and it was like over
20 gigs for a what was that twenty five
minute video I've been flying goat took
up so much so many gigabytes so I
actually I do have an external hard
drive I bought I bought a four terabyte
hard drive a few years ago I got a new
laptop recently with two terabytes so
I'm and still have enough space actually
Google photos allows unlimited storage
for 1080p video which is quite nice so
that's kind of a backup method you can
watch so you can actually watch the vaad
even if I'm still alive I think right
let's see so here's my channel so if you
want to watch kind of in the past you
you can't rewind here overall its
inception oh this is so weird and so
inception Wow so I could do this and
then oh is too much fun anyway um you go
to videos you go to then you click this
and now now you can go back and watch in
the past so just a quick tutorial for
confused people there is a feature on
Twitch I think some people have enabled
we're only subs can watch vod's which I
have considered enabling just to have
some valid security also to prevent
people from using software to download
my vods and posts the whole thing on
YouTube anyway
um okay yeah I don't know don't know who
I'll be playing between Gauri or Cheska
more me or maybe Gauri will play chess
Kim how does the pairing system work
pairing system because usually it's
based on reading but it might be based
on it could be based on color too
actually
mmm oh with a Dutch system hmm okay not
enough time to prepare
Oh as Dutch does Dutch system use
tiebreaks Dutch system I reach you
slowly to internalize that I'm playing
chess Kim okay let's play let's play
London so I I'm not playing Gauri Wow
Gauri dodge me oh that's so sad
opponents blitz bullets okay not so high
rating bullet Oh Queen b6 in b6 is a
line let's play 93 yeah you so excite c4
can't complain with this if Queen times
b2 I would have been slightly
disappointed Queen c6 wait neither three
here I'm 95 ideas
interesting upon playing really quickly
but is black playing accurately maybe it
was a weird position already so there's
a move I want to play but I don't want
to say it's upon the mic you watching so
apologies but I'll probably have to
think silently I'm gonna play rugby one
let's be safe safe and practical
yeah so I wanted to do probably now it's
not gonna be too relevant
I wanted to play Knight g5 but the line
with Queen takes me to is a bit but if
he it may have just led to a trade but
this looks a bit more solid
if takes on b2 after night a three there
is might be five it gets very
complicated though okay so some position
it was like kind of ideal London
position I guess can't complain with
this
I spent some time in the opening block
played a slightly unusual move order
I'm curious who Gary's playing Jerry's
playing probably playing someone who had
a four and a half out of five points
Locke takes on e5 I have a choice here I
could take with nine pawn or Bishop
you'll take with Knight
I mean yeah most logical it sets up some
Queen maneuvering ninety seven black
wants to trade so there is queen h5 here
like Queen h5g six expected here hmm
have a very similar structure earlier
there should be decent weight there's
also considering the sack but it's
probably no good there's also g6 and
then I take but okay let's play queen h6
if takes I'll have some choice to make
and down a bit of time down about 30
seconds thanks for the bits jabs 11 been
flying Gold's rule never sack is that a
rule I don't think I've heard that one
there's always retreat which might mean
the same thing I want to say I want the
sack on g6 by Saigon g6 that probably
just leads to perpetual would love to
like teleporter rook to h3 and then meet
I mean there's some like each rh5 idea
before can be a possibility but even if
I'm not like getting a strong attack
positionally it should still be very
pleasant okay black wants to play this
that makes sense
and ig4 is kind of interesting
Nagi for Bishop g7 Queen h3 some h5 it
gets weird I might play Queen h3 right
away actually very reminiscent of the
the previous scheme where I got the pawn
to e5 and then I kept only play left six
we traded I had a four later and we got
that position aligned game so yeah I'm
more inclined to take with the pawn and
there's Bishop h6 ideas as well I could
start with Queen may be Queen here
it's so similar to the previous game
like if a pony plays f6 and then takes
it could be close to identical how be
funny but I guess I've in another game
my rook was on each one so I had this h4
idea which is less strong here but I
still might go for h4 as bishop is still
kind of out of play
yeah so this is a very key idea I
probably want to play rook rook team on
to meet Bishop b5 with Bishop c2 just
avoid the Trail of Lights where bishops
so I want to keep this Bishop for
attacking purposes
and yeah though the plan is to just use
the each pawn to soften the kingside it
would be nice to on castle but that's
it's slightly on slightly illegal at
least as of now but maybe King H to work
h1 or maybe I can Keane walk just like
Nigel Schwartz there's actually some
similarities for the Nigel Schwartz team
on game or if I get my Bishop to f6 and
then the Queen we trade on f6 and then
the King walks to h6 but that's probably
in the very distant future a black
allowing each five yeah I think black
probably should have played h5 to
prevent this cuz now I'm gonna leave the
tension there's always gonna be looming
ideas of takes or h6 and black never
wants to take on each five oh I forgot
about that move good move but maybe I
can take maybe it's okay Bishop e2
coming out of nowhere also I can i sack
the exchange probably no good I'm also
thinking of sacking the pawn and then
like Queen h4 g4 the problem is is there
a problem
wait a minute rook d2 takes them in
Queen h4 I guess there's takes it gets
weird takes takes and then g4 I mean
taking is probably the simple option
even though it's still complex and efore
will be a move at some points matrix
isn't working okay so I don't think I'm
too scared of takes because I'm I take
here and I take back there's more
expecting F takes yeah this is this is
looking very fine if Bishop here
probably f3 King F 2 and then rook h1
Bishop e5
Black has the same plan but blacks plan
doesn't work who's king here I check I
think
yeah I just want to play rook h1 king g1
Queen h4 and then mates so uncaf sling
kind of mean black is probably gonna try
and run to the center but that's not the
safest place oh my time
so yeah let's start with the swift King
here I have rookie to 7 yeah the bishop
is gonna kind of be stuck probably
rookie to 7 anyway now the King's tied
down to the Bishop a5 doesn't scare me
Queen each twos a move keeping
everything covered yeah keeping the
defense now the Queen's not really
overworked - either I want a sack no I
have a sack you're not seeing the sack
he's a sack that works
there's g4 kind of a neat move idea g5
tricky position let's play off three
always play off three idea to clear the
second ring for the rook and now I'm
threatening some force mates
yeah I think this is force mates
wreckage too because earlier there is
some Queen a female but oh it's not
means well it's not me yet oh that's
gonna be mates so here here oh f 6
though that's not me Wow and I'm down
the exchange but it looks so good ship
g6 still looks decent g5 coming
okay so that was not a clean finish at
all I think my foot actually had a
Chancellor to survive but now I'm I'm
not the bishop this is looking pretty
good
I'm this okay Wow I think I could have I
completely missed out five because if I
check here the King runs oh I could have
won the Queen though I should have done
that I mean this also looked winning
there there is a free Brooke man missed
a lot of things there I think you're
like after 85 um so in this position
black and take I'm just I'm telling the
rook I don't have meat man yeah I could
have very easy losses I was ill play
Bishop each seven and pray but the King
runs weird game yeah Queen digs g6 also
a moon I mean there's this move there
probably a lot of ways to him computer
gives ya so many ways so what was the
finish oh there's two games ongoing Oh
Gauri also won but my tie breaks are
superior it looks like that's so sad I
didn't play Gauri the two the two
streamers the top seeds hey liquid sword
breaking 1700 and blitz congratulations
maybe I can take some credits
hey it's confetti
yeah good games everyone thanks everyone
for playing I hope people enjoyed that
had some intense games
hey it's as orange popcorn didn't you
enter the tournament as the lowest rated
player or maybe towards the bottom but
finish with a plus score yeah nice to
see so many people false lobster yeah
there's some random names that I
recognize some people that have
definitely played before so yeah I don't
know if I'll put the whole thing on
YouTube but yeah it's some people saying
hi to YouTube